♪ ♪ ♪
- Mehdi Bamhad est un exemple
de métissage réussi.
Originaire du Maroc,
Mehdi Bahmad est arrivé avec
sa famille à Granby à l'âge
de 8 ans.
MEHDI BAHMAD
Artiste visuel et musicien
- Il y a quelque chose aussi...
je me sens aussi peut-être plus
confortable d'explorer ici.
Évidemment au Maroc je sens...
c'est sûr qu'il y a un petit peu
plus de... de réticenses. C'est
juste qu'au Maroc, il y a
quelque chose de physique qui
se passe chaque fois que
j'arrive là-bas... il y a
quelque chose ... mon corps
communique très facilement puis
naturellement avec l'endroit.
- Auteur-compositeur-interprète,
danseur, artiste visuel,
Mehdi Bahmad aime brouiller
les lignes.
- Quand j'écris, je compose,
je pense aux clips en même
temps. Je pense aux pochettes,
j'arrive là-bas... il y a
quelque chose ... mon corps
communique très facilement puis
naturellement avec l'endroit.
- Auteur-compositeur-interprète,
♪ ♪ ♪
- Visuellement, il détourne des
symboles traditionnels pour leur
insufler une grande modernité.
Il navigue avec fluidité et avec
grâce entre symboles masculins
et feminins.
- Je pense que ça s'est fait
nautrellement. J'ai tout le
temps été attiré vers ce qui
est dit plus feminin, entre
guilement, et c'est toujours
de façon très instinctive
et naturelle.
- Un liberté qui peut choquer.
Récemment interviewé par un
populaire site web marocain,
les réactions ont été vives.
Pour le meilleur, mais aussi
pour le pire.
- La réception aussi, c'est pas
nécessairement la même au Maroc.
Je pense que les gens sont un
peu plus... un peu plus choqués.
Tu sais, il peut y avoir de
la polémique juste pour une
pose que je vais prendre même
pas pour quelque chose que
je porte. Même si j'ai pas
de rouge à lèvres ou de vernis.
- Ses oeuvres sont exposées
à Montréal, au Hangar 77, sur
la rue Bernard, dans le plateau
Mont-Royal jusqu'à la fin
septembre. Il sera en concert
le 22 août dans le cadre
du  Festival Mode et Design.
♪ ♪ ♪
-Mehdi Bahmad un artiste
singulier,  qui fait bouger les
lignes.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, M